il semble que lady Susan va enfin vous rendre visite
Lady Susan banner félicitations pour
être sur le point de recevoir le flirt le plus
accompli de toute l'Angleterre cette
femme est un démon j'ai de l'argent et le
mari
m'excuse d'être arrivé de cette façon quelle
charmante famille pose le
lien permanent entre vous et  Lady Susan
détruirait chaque confort de nos vies
avec plaisir mr.  le cours de la colombe est
beau n'est-il pas dans un CAF comme nous
ne sommes pas comme Mannering bien sûr est-il là
James serait très riche plutôt simple
boules vertes bien rangées idéales comment on les
appelle des pois Susan arrête Mannering en ville
composent n'importe quoi de nombreuses créatures brillantes
leurs encouragements  d'autres hommes n'étaient donc
pas Toria ce sont de viles colonies
vous pensez que mon mari a dérangé madame
si vous allez être jaloux vous
ne devriez pas épouser un aussi charmant eux arrêtez Lady
Susan allez-y monsieur je vais vous faire
fouetter vous n'avez jamais rencontré  lui non je le
connais bien je ne parlerais jamais à un
étranger comme ça
combien de prétendants d'une grande sagesse une
jeune femme peut-elle s'attendre à trouver de nos jours
n'en connais aucun